bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
stream tire comme FR avec Fatou salut
Fatou salut tout le monde
on est prêt pour cette nouvelle journée
de proces League donc avec un match ici
hyper important entre Canada
chess Wizard donc une équipe avec pas
mal de très très bons joueurs on aura du
coup dans cette équipe Raoul qui est
très bambide Sirk à 26-50 on aura
shimanov qui aussi est 2006 très bon
blixeur on aura aussi Denise Liv lasavik
qui nous avait impressionné pendant le
championnat du monde de partir rapide et
Blitz un jeune joueur de
pyélo Russie me semble 2529 mais jeune
et en blitz hyper hyper fort et bien sûr
comme féminine ils auront on voit
l'écran ici c'est pas Fatou ça sera avec
qui a été champion du monde
féminin mais pas encore Fatou et donc
Charles
il fait un petit peu la tronche et il
sera il a l'air très heureux il sera du
coup au premier échec et de son équipe
et du coup on aura en deuxième je
reviens de vin de Forest qui est aussi
très connu dans le circuit quasiment
2700 Elo on aura rasvane près au tout
qui sera aussi au troisième échec donc
c'est un grand maître à 2500 hello qui
avait parfois prié aussi
dans le match et comme féminine on aura
du coup Jade ou Elite Miley qui a 2200
hello donc un match assez disputé
intéressant avec 45 qui
pourrait faire un 4 sur 4 dans un match
comme ça parce qu'il a quand même bon
les joueurs de l'éditeur sont tous très
dangereux mais 45 donc 4 sur 4 de 45 et
ici très possible tandis que la féminine
de
1200 euros c'est très fort mais par
rapport à l'équipe d'en face ou le moins
bon le bon vélo c'est 2521 c'est pas
facile donc c'est un match qui est
vraiment très disputé avec un grand
favori chez Canada chagrin champion du
monde mais aussi la féminine qui est
assez faible par rapport à l'équipe
adverse donc en tout cas match très
intéressant qui va qui va commencer en
quelques instants Fatou j'ai oublié de
t'envoyer le lien mais ça va arriver et
la partie qui a déjà commencé ici c'est
une
une rousse au lit moi j'ai l'impression
avec ces trois faut prendre H3 ça touche
ton voisin
on peut préciser aussi que cela les deux
équipes sont en tête en fait ont tout
gagné on fait même du mal dans les
premières phases de championnats les
deux équipes ont perdu un match
elles ont perdu un match mais gagner
deux c'est ça
par rapport à l'enjeu du match et c'est
bien fado que tu le soulignes c'est
qu'en fait l'équipe qui va gagner ce
match et automatiquement qualifiée pour
du coup la phase suivante et le perdant
sera comme l'équipe de whisky hier qui a
gagné contre les
les Brésiliens du coup
dos au mur un objet de gagner le
prochain match
pour se qualifier donc du coup voilà
enfin tout je t'ai envoyé
tout va bien voilà donc du coup j'ai ça
j'ai un tout petit truc à faire enfin
tout si tu peux gérer un petit peu faut
juste que je mette un dernier truc en
place
les caméras
un petit peu la tête
il est pas encore totalement heureux il
est pas encore gagnant
ça peut venir donc là c'est
ça joue comme toute la vie on peut on
peut voir le catch sur 4 pour Carsen
mais
ça va être compliqué et c'est
ce qui est plus compliqué donc ça va
être pour la féminine on n'a pas encore
vu on n'a pas vu les autres expliquer ce
que ça donne mais la féminine qui va
avoir beaucoup de mal alors que le reste
des parties c'est
que des grands maîtres donc ça
c'est quand même un peu plus serré
ok j'ai compris
[Musique]
va avoir du mal à avancer
je pense que les blancs
les blancs aimeraient l'avancée pour
pour enlever la faiblesse mais c'est un
petit peu compliqué de la structure en
noir
donc
un Magnus il fait un petit peu la tête
mais ils sont connectés à cet art aussi
les joueurs je crois que Maggie c'était
encore en train de grignoter quand il
est arrivé donc
je suis prêt je suis prêt j'ai réglé mes
réglages pas tout il y a le temps aussi
parfait et donc du coup voilà donc ça
c'est la partie Carson avec le noir
contre costaignan Coste championne du
monde
je suis plus que l'année d'ailleurs et
d'ailleurs on voit qu'elle a le drapeau
suisse tu vois un an tu vois pas moi
mais en fait elle a un rapport de Suisse
et ça ça fait depuis quelques jours en
fait et ben avec tout ce qui se passe
souvent avec la Russie etc la guerre en
Ukraine et ben il y a beaucoup de
joueurs en fait qui ont quitté la
Fédération et du coup elle est partie
jouer pour la Suisse
et même le drapeau le drapeau russe et
pas été banni ouais ouais
en fait
et on peut penser à un petit F5 qui va
arriver qui peut être sympa
[Musique]
c'est pas le bon fou malheureusement
c'est un fou qui par rapport à la
structure en fait tu vois les blancs
souvent ils vont donner le foot 15
blanche contre le cavalier pour casser
un peu la structure et ensuite une fois
que le fou te casse blanche des blancs a
été échangé on met généralement tous les
pions sur blanc pour jouer sur case noir
et pour tuer le footclasse bon
inverse donc le foot case blanche des
Noirs bah écoute il a pas beaucoup de
cases c'est pas une super pièce mais
qu'avec les cinq c'est intéressant non
seulement pour manger le fou mais aussi
vos projets F4 intéressant
alors du coup cette partie elle
m'intéresse il y avait eu alors il y a
longtemps je crois que c'était en 2007
ou en 2008
il y avait un championnat du monde de
Blitz avec une partie entre
costenioc contre Carlson il y a une
vidéo sur Internet qui tourne si vous
voulez vous pouvez la retrouver je pense
à assez facilement et quinzen à tous
c'est une pièce à jouer un coup et
finalement il a repris sa pièce il avait
joué autre chose
donc après j'imagine que les gens sont
peut-être encore jouer après cet
événement mais il y avait eu un vieux
truc comme ça ou car ça n'avait perdu
par toucher jouer
c'était il y a longtemps en 2007 en 2008
mais en 2007 2008 cars 2800
donc déjà un gros monstre du circuit
alors est-ce que tu veux qu'on iPhone un
petit tour du coup
des stades enfin tout
on pourra aller voir ce qui se passe
table 2 on a du coup vent de Forest
contre contre la zavik donc là vous avez
qu'on avait dit que c'est un joueur qui
qui est très très bon en blitz qui a
2529 mais très dangereux faut pas faire
attention
donc voilà voir un peu ce qui se passe
donc là c'est l'ouverture c'est ça qui a
été joué donc c'est ça que c'est
intéressant ça prend de l'espace mais E4
la réponse active importante si je veux
pas E4 c'est noir qu'elle a joué à 5
eux-mêmes et cassé le centre
et donc au cas du coup
peut-être encore de la position
je t'entends pas Fatou je sais pas si tu
veux parler
Kevin que j'ai contacté juste avant
stream parce que je pensais que je
streamais avec lui aujourd'hui mais
mon message
[Musique]
je comprenais pas
tant besoin
donc demain je stream à la même heure
avec Pro Évolution échec du chat ça va
être beau
bienvenue à tous et merci merci Kévin
yes bienvenue à tous et toi
vive la Suisse et Jester qui est
maintenant dans son lit
dans son ça fédération et ben une
championne du monde d'échec en Suisse
voilà
je suis fatigué
Alexandra costenioc qui a été champion
du monde et qui joue d'ailleurs pour le
club de Clichy
avec des grandes forest c'est marrant
alors
G6 ok donc il y avait une petite menace
de de maths en H7 là haut
présente
très vite
d'ailleurs ici est-ce qu'on ferait pas
un petit B4 pas tout
histoire de garder un peu la tension de
garder cette structure saine
il mange ici
là faut regarder là c'est pas que là si
je veux peut-être
[Musique]
j'aurais peut-être fait B4 direct
je sais pas ce que ça donne ça
pas encore s'exprimer
on n'aime pas trop
de sortir un petit peu de tout ça faut
voir aussi parce que là
la dame noire déjà pas beaucoup de cases
elle prend la seule place du cavalier
non c'est clair mais en fait sur long
terme j'ai quand même une paire de fou
et comme j'ai fait G6 et ben ton four en
V1 il a plu vraiment grand chose à faire
pour l'instant
donc si j'arrive à
trouver une solution pour ce problème de
cavalier que tu as mentionné et ben je
pense qu'en fait les noirs sont très
bien
parce que par défaut encore une fois
tout à l'heure tu l'as dit j'adore les
fous ça c'est pareil les gens
du coup
alors je sais pas mais là je regarde
d'ailleurs la partie
là il y a le fou qui peut venir en A6
des fois même s'il y a quand même du B5
à se renvoyer
de mettre une tour en
8 et puis ressortir le cavalier avec
être F8
j'appuie etc
[Musique]
donc par contre si je mange en cinq
d'abord
manger de là je pensais pas un bon coup
j'aurais pu passer etc et sur pions
qui pourrait me dire sur les 15 blanches
après c'est quand même peur d'avoir ma
carte qui peut aussi poser problème donc
c'est pas si facile
mon four a pas de bonne case non plus à
voir il y a eu à 5 d'abord OK et je
pense qu'il va il va falloir du coup
prise et là peut-être fois 6 ou est-ce
que peut-être moi je pensais aussi à ton
début tout à l'heure bon je cavalier F8
et cavalier aussi le cavalier depuis le
6 qui attaque quand même les deux
faiblesses là
c'est intéressant on peut expliquer ton
le a5 avec ta variante justement tu
parlais de damacata qui pouvait faire
des problèmes en fait taper sur les
faiblesses et là en faisant un simple
qui s'enlève la faiblesse donc
il garde que le petit pion C6 mais qui
lui de toute façon ne peut pas bouger
donc
à base de défauts voyez un petit
vis-à-vis l'un entre dans mes cavaliers
bon pour l'instant c'est défendu à part
deux pièces mais un jour peut-être un
carré prend à 5 pourrait surgir aussi
nulle part donc faire attention à plein
de tactiques mais là en terme
positionnel je pense que le cavalier a
aussi ce serait une super case pour lui
pour attaquer là et se placer et bloquer
un peu la colonne ouverte tu as tout
revu de cavalier fluide cavalier aussi
ce serait génial j'aime beaucoup la
position grande forest parce que ben moi
je vois de fou moi je kiffe les fous
vous savez
salut
à tous notre petit tour on est à Préaux
tout ça
et sûrement un joueur d'origine roumaine
je n'ai pas
trop en étymologie des noms mais je te
fais confiance je pense que
demander sinon elle
normalement il est assez calé sur le
sujet
du coup du coup voilà alors le score
canard tu l'as sur le chat enfin sur le
stream pas besoin d'aller voir de la
faire la commande regarde tu as de score
qui est en bas en dessous de chez qui
c'est le score du match bon c'est le
début il y a 0-0 pour l'instant et à
droite sous Fatou et Ben et tout moi
aussi et ben on a le score de la ronde
en cours il y a 0 0 c'est le début de la
ronde encore une fois
donc
voilà t'inquiète
donc du coup si maintenant il va falloir
que si maintenant c'est un très bon
blitzer il y avait il m'avait adopté en
Bullet
et ouais c'est un très très bon joueur
de Blitz et Bullet plus de 3000
sur le site internet
c'est pas mal c'est costaud et après
autour il nous avait il nous avait
vraiment impressionné aussi lors de son
match de la dernière ronde de la
processe League il avait été monstrueux
donc avec 200480 il avait fait un truc
genre 3 sur 4 contre les 2006 2007 il
avait été vraiment très fort donc il a
fait ses preuves en tout cas et il est
carrément très dangereux et capable de
battre n'importe qui dans cet endroit
donc c'est vraiment une bonne une bonne
une bonne recrue pour cette équipe
canadienne en plus c'est vraiment un
genre local c'est quand même Canada
chessbra et lui il est canadiens pour de
vrai enfin pour de vrai
mais il joue pour le Canada en tout cas
voilà et merci beaucoup pour le prime
merci à toi
et donc voilà et donc du coup alors ça
c'est une partie un peu chaude où il se
passe plein de choses donc je pense
c'est une Française ouais et trois
quatre cinq six on égalité de pion les
Noirs ont un TAC ici les blancs on leur
attaquent un peu plus lente j'ai
l'impression j'ai une colonne B mais
tout a l'air d'être solide
on leur attaque à l'endroit mais faut
voir qu'à la dame ils ont aussi ils ont
aussi des cases en fait
bien tenir la position j'aime beaucoup
les Noirs mais aussi il y a pas
d'affaires de foot en fait la part de
foot pour que vous comprenez bien un
petit peu
ben ça dépend de la position il y a pas
c'est pas parce qu'on dit où il a peur
de fou c'est fort que non non il faut
toujours la prendre quand la position
elle est ouverte
et ben la barre de fou est très forte
par contre quand tout est bloqué un peu
comme ici et ben la part de fou elle
devient pas si peur par exemple là vous
voyez ce foulage pas grand chose il se
fout là étape sur rien donc c'est par
défaut n'est pas terrible ici par contre
vous voyez j'aime bien sur d'apprendre
ici par exemple
peut-être il y a un monde ou un jour je
peux échanger mettre mon fou ici
ouvrir là et en fait ouvrir tous mes
fous et là je serai fort donc les Noirs
ont bien raison de ne pas vouloir
échanger les dates
à 4 donc je pense qu'il veut il va vous
baisser
bon en tout cas une partie intéressante
là il va falloir trouver une solution H4
fois H2
mais j'aime pas les blancs je suis pas
fan les blancs un petit peu
après ils doivent jouer mais bon ça
reste pas simple tu vois cavalier B5 ça
fait peur ça quasiment mat derrière
franchement il faut trouver des cons
quoi pour le noir pas facile
[Musique]
ou pas mais c'est chaud c'est chaud
c'est pas simple ça c'est compliqué en
fait mais bon ok je préfère les noirs
[Musique]
chaud très très chaud et rapidement on
va voir un petit peu ma médov contre
jade on va l'appeler jade parce que elle
a dit prénom et dit nom de famille elle
sera plus simple pour moi
donc jade c'est fini alors oui on a
l'affichage du score de Carlson donc
visiblement oui c'est fini mais on va
aller voir on va aller voir dans un
instant donc Jacques il y a une belle
bienvenue du tout
et merci beaucoup pour ce pour ce raid
alors thé vert je l'ai vu tilt pour la
première fois de ma vie c'était ça là
son titre c'était pas le tilt donc
le titre c'était quoi le titre
je sais plus c'était pas ça a dû changer
en cours de style parce qu'il a dit que
c'était
irrémédiable en tout cas merci pour ton
aide thé vert menteur
on se fâche pas donc sauter d'amande
pour ceux qui connaissent pas la chaîne
de tvamente je vous invite à tous aller
la visiter
généralement il te parle
et immigrés on va on va revoir la partie
un petit peu après là on finit notre
tour avec la table 4 rapidement et puis
on y retourne on va aller voir ce qui
s'est passé
le centre s'ouvre en général dans la
dans la
solimose ça peut être bien des fois pour
les pour les noirs et toutes les pièces
qui s'activent
on voit vraiment car de scène qui ouvre
vraiment vite et bien
qu'elle va laisser 5 puis on passait qui
se crée c'est juste
juste trop difficile on reprend FC sans
fous il y a rien contrôle tout
je reviens ici attaquer 2
et la du coup je mangeais de comment il
a fini d'un projet 3 il y a pas déjà
fait
mon pion qu'avant j'aime la Scave de
maths j'arrive pas à faire de flèche
mais je vais réussir
et du coup ok personne qui ouvre le
score on va même être qui
qui gagne de son côté aussi on va aller
voir là très vite si vous voulez contre
ventes forest
mais on a vu qu'il y avait un gros
problème autant donc c'est pas c'est pas
trop étonnant c'est du craquer vraiment
dans ta boîte en plus c'était mal parti
tu vois regarde canard sur le tout en
dessous de nous tu as le score tu vois
Carson 1-0 contre que c'est mieux voilà
tout est écrit sur le sur le sur le
stream normalement tout à l'heure
et en dessous l'échiquier c'est le score
du match parce qu'il y aura plusieurs il
y aura plusieurs sept voilà
on veut pas lire pourtant tu sais que
moi je lis bien
ça fait longtemps que j'ai pas lu mais
je lise un jour ok H4
et
donc position à s'équilibrer mais je
préfère les Noirs parce que ce fou en
fait il peut être plus fort les 14 sont
ouvertes tu vois qu'il y a un problème
sur G7
et ça peut craquer à un moment donné il
y a 20 secondes quand même pour
pour les blancs mais c'est un joueur qui
est très rapide
et du coup je pense qu'il veut
clairement
s'en sortir avec les blancs en tout cas
c'est pas parce qu'il est mal au temps
que
tu vas se faire avoir
[Musique]
tu peux pas comprendre
mes rêves sont trop compliqués
en fait
mais la raison hein je prends la il
prend la et plus ça échange plus ça ne
change de faire mieux alors si on peut
aller voir la partie de prêt auto parce
que je vois que c'est le bordel intégral
et quand c'est comme ça il y a tout qui
est en prise on ne comprend rien
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ici qui est
mon S7
est-ce que je peux manger là
tout simplement
et je me lasse plein de choses je menace
la tour je me lasse des Tour Eiffel
ce qu'il a fait
on n'a pas envie de pousser H2 bien sûr
c'est l'histoire du pion parapluie donc
on va plus se cacher c'est ça et là faut
pas faut justement lui rentrer dedans
donc on prend et on essaye de lui foncer
dessus et il doit y avoir un matin ça
pue ça pue un petit peu le mat mais
alors en fait je vois que j'ai un petit
souci en fait parce que les caméras sont
pas toujours en direct
alors les gens quand ils ont fini la
partie ouais des fois ben ils partent
il y a un petit décalage ils sont le
score est en affichage des scores et les
parties sont un petit peu en avance par
rapport à nous et on voit que vent de
Forest agréé sa partie c'est incroyable
comment il a fait
on est parti de seconde
et alors ça fait quoi ça fait fouger 7
cavalier à 5 fois H6 ça m'avait vu T4
il a mangé ici
et le pion qui avance la cavalier à 5
pardon
de laservic qui était pas loin de faire
nul mais comme ce pion maintenant on est
très dangereux hein faut commencer à
faire attention
je sais pas ce qu'on aurait pu jouer
pour tenir la lune
peut-être un coup de style cavalier
d'écart ramener un peu les pièces vers
ici
va être bien mais après même si des
quatre
saisons
est-ce que je viens il y a toujours le
petit fou des deux
forest qui a essayé de de mettre la
pression
de prendre ceci c'est de faire cavalier
c'est trop
ouais mais je fais quoi en fait
je pense qu'il faut manger là
et sur ça
et c'est là qu'il a fait cavalier là qui
est pas bon
peut-être juste
et après je vais essayer de venir
attaquer lui ou devenir ramener mon roi
même faire F3 pour changer les pions
du coup bah écoutez ça nous fait deux
deux dans ce match donc un score on va
dire assez logique dans le sens que tous
les favoris ont gagné on va caractériser
le champion du monde qui a gagné sa
partie on a besoin de Forest aussi qui
vient sa partie et shimanov ainsi que ma
médof ont gagné aussi donc du coup c'est
pour l'instant
on va dire un score assez logique
je vais juste hop vous préparer les
caméras pour cette belle ronde 2 enfin
deuxième set on va dire
et alors je prends les apparuments
et on va recommencer dans un carrément
de la ronde de ça va faire tout du coup
on va voir 45 avec les blancs
dans cette première partie qui du coup
aura
les blancs dans la deuxième qui va
affronter
qui va affronter du coup
[Musique]
Denis lazavik qui vient de perdre ici à
l'instant contre vente forest
donc hop là je suis en train de mettre
la caméra
on a ça
au deuxième on va avoir du couvent de
Forest avec les Blancs
donc le pain en dessous et bonne soirée
va jouer contre
costenioc championne du monde alors je
sais pas en quelle année elle a toujours
pas du monde je me suis un peu
c'était en
[Musique]
du coup qui va avoir les blancs dans
cette partie
contre
race van préaux tout donc c'est une
partie importante celle-là
bon toutes les parties sont importantes
mais
toutes les parties sont importantes donc
ma méthode blanc contre ras van
pré-retour
plus dans les la troisième ou la
quatrième ronde parce que les maths sont
plus serrés donc c'est un peu tout rien
donc
qui est là il aura les blancs
les blancs contre jade
où es-tu tu es là et elle est noire
et ben c'est parfait les caméras sont
prêtes de mon côté
on va on va bientôt commencer on a 45
contre laservic sont prêts à commencer
je vais vous mettre bien sûr les parties
hop les parties en direct dès qu'elles
auront commencé
mais ouais en tout cas c'est une belle
affiche un tournoi cette ronde avec je
vous rappelle à la clé une qualification
[Musique]
pour
pour je crois que c'est des cartes de
finale va tout
je l'ai pas sous les yeux mais alors
pour l'instant de qualifier je peux vous
le dire je peux vous le dire en
qualifier on a du coup les Indian Yugi
on a les Gotham Knights Gotham Knight
c'est l'équipe pour moi qui est la
grosse favorite de championnat qui a
gagné trois matchs sur trois et dans les
trois matchs qu'elle a gagné il a deux
qu'elle a gagné au bout de trois sets
tu vois donc c'est assez ouf
et ensuite en troisième on a les
Shanghai Tiger donc c'est l'équipe des
Chinois emmenés par Wailly
et ensuite à deux points on a beaucoup
de d'équipes donc déjà on a les vitof
Wizard qui joue ici donc c'était de
mamedov on a aussi Canada cette voix
donc 47 qu'il faut en ce moment on a
aussi les norwegnomes qu'on verra demain
jouer on sera en direct avec Kevin
thérieux contre l'équipe de team mgd1
c'est l'équipe des des Indiens avec du
coup
erikasi etc
et ensuite avec deux points et ben on a
encore du coup les trois chiens de
bouledogs donc les Croates avec aussi
l'équipe de Blitz qui est aussi du coup
avec deux points donc tous ces équipes
là doivent encore faire un point
pour se qualifier pour les pour la suite
donc à savoir que les croix chats
bouledogs et Blitz ils sont encore un
match à jouer et obligation de gagner le
match pour ce qualifier dans les quarts
de finale alors qu'ici même si jamais
imaginons une équipe remporte donc on va
dire au hasard l'équipe de 45 Canada
chazebra gagne ce match est-ce qu'il
faut automatiquement pour les quarts de
finale pendant que les lévitov ont
encore une chance de se qualifier dans
le match suivant peu importe contre qui
joueront il faut arriver à trois
victoires 3 matchs gagnés pour l'instant
ils sont tous à deux points
ensuite on a du coup tous les équipes
avec
Californie unicornes
gardenstade tout ça qu'ils ont encore un
match à jouer voir un petit peu s'ils
arrivent à se qualifier mais en tout cas
en équipe éliminée on a les brasils
capybaraas qui est par du hier contre
contre Blitz on a aussi des perles
lambers
et Kevin hier il était complètement fou
sur son stream parce que non mais c'est
vrai c'était ouf la fin du match était
ouf et en fait
il y a eu des partages alors qu'il
aurait pu ne pas avoir des partages et
les départages étaient foutu et en fait
ça retournait au dernier moment enfin
bref
allez finance mais bon ça fait 6
spectacle qui est aussi beau à voir en
tout cas c'est cool alors est-ce que du
coup j'ai la ronde qui a commencé j'ai
l'impression que Carlton a l'air d'avoir
[Musique]
d'être tac
oui effectivement
c'est en vacances peut-être que c'est
moi je trouve pas de l'appareils
apparaissent et des fois ils
apparaissent là c'est un peu bizarre
qu'au champion du monde en 2008 ça a été
recherché 2008 merci beaucoup j'avais
dit quoi 2010 OK
ok je me suis trompé
il y avait une histoire c'était
je sais plus si c'était cette année-là
où il y avait un championnat du monde
qui s'était joué dans un pays
c'était où déjà je sais plus
mais je crois qu'il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de joueurs qui n'ont pas pu y
aller parce que c'est un pays qui était
à moitié en guerre
et c'est assez chaud je sais plus
le monde si c'était pas
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie de bêtises
bon je ne dirais pas de bêtises je
dirais rien
je sais plus mais je pense que c'est un
pays du style bon j'ai pas dit
il y a un style
si vous avez les rêves dans le chat
n'hésitez pas à nous
réponses salut à tous à tous ceux qui
ont pas dit bonjour et au spectateur de
YouTube aussi parce qu'il y en a qui
nous regarde et oui
et d'ailleurs il paraît
on t'attend c'est ça on a 71% non
si c'est ça oui non c'est 29%
[Musique]
des 4 images
par contre la caméra sont encore là
pourquoi
il manque un joueur les caméras qui se
sont
que c'est le cas
effectivement le meilleur spectacle
ça a commencé chez moi mais j'ai une
caméra qui est pas bonne en fait si vous
voulez la caméra de de là on va
continuer en haut mais apparemment c'est
parce que j'ai un bug de caméra et que
l'adversaire est parti est sorti de la
conversation de la de la de la convo
et du coup bah écoute problème de
connexion
mais il est pas si tu veux il est pas
dans la dans le
il est pas dans le dans la caméra voilà
il est pas dans le dans le groupe
le club se questionne un petit peu aussi
sur le fait de jouer en prison ciel ou
non qui que des caméras pas d'arbitre
vous avez quand même les caméras bon là
qui normalement de doivent marcher et si
vous regardez bien bon là car c'est on
va pas trop mais je peux vous changer de
caméra après un petit peu
vous allez voir souvent des caméras par
exemple si je vous mets la médoff
regardez je vais mettre
simple il y a plusieurs caméras chez une
même personne
il est en bas et maintenant en fait sa
partie et ben on va on voit la caméra
enfin c'est un téléphone derrière qui
filme derrière lui en fait si vous
voulez il y a une caméra qui est qui est
bon sur vous
vous avez en plus une autre caméra qui
surveille vos mouvements et ce que vous
faites et en plus quand vous participez
vous avez obligation de partager votre
écran à l'arbitre parce qu'il y a il y a
un arbitre
il y a un arbitre
qui s'occupe de ça via zoom qui leur
donne un peu dans cette instruction donc
ils sont partagées avec tout ce qui est
donc pas le droit de de
je sais pas de d'aller sur
sur certains sites ou même d'avoir une
aide ordinateur ou quoi que ce soit ah
oui c'est surveillé donc il y a pas
d'arbitre dans la salle mais en fait ils
sont hyperpliqués des joueurs et puis vu
l'enjeu vu tout ça je pense qu'ils sont
pas envie non plus de tu vois c'est
quand même chaud quand même tu triches
en équipe en vrai bon déjà en vrai c'est
chaud mais en équipe c'est
ah oui c'est pire en équipe parce que
tu écoutes il faut confiance enfin voilà
c'est c'est pour moi c'est pire que tout
en fait
tu vas un peu loin j'en sais rien je
pense pas je pense ça s'arrête de
l'écran
de toute manière c'est tous les gens ne
peuvent pas se déplacer tout le temps
pour tout et c'est pour ça que les
compétitions en ligne sont aussi
sympa après
des manières des moyens de moins de le
faire quand même mais je veux dire à un
moment donné
les joueurs là sont quasiment tous genre
professionnel grande renommée
ils sont pas là pour ça et puis les
cadences sont rapides donc
je pense pas
je pense pas qu'il est riche
4 c'est pas pour rien donc il garde
sécurise un petit peu son roi mais en
gardant sa potentielle attaque
ok alors on va voir enfin un petit tour
alors du coup ici on a
vente forest contre costenio que je vois
des caméras associées
en bas qui a son linge étendu sur son
armoire
donc le costaignan qui a un arbre de
Noël un peu bizarre donc
on va pas se moquer de la
du coup ok donc ça c'est une sorte
d'espagnol d'échange je pense que qui a
dû avoir lieu avec un fou français 6
tout à l'heure et maintenant un autre
truc qui a eu lieu en aussi se voir
rapidement ce qui s'est passé
genre espagnol
et ça avait l'air d'être un peu les deux
il y a tout prend foutrant ok bah écoute
je connais pas du tout cette solution
voilà donc la structure elle est moche
mais les plombs contre quand même pas
mal de cases centrales donc c'est pas
sûr que ça soit si dégueu visuellement
ça fait moche mais en fait en vrai
peut-être que c'est pas si long on
accepte plus facilement les pions
doublés quand ils sont assez serrés à la
protection du roi ou au centre pour
contrôler pas mal de cases et empêcher
pêcher l'avancée adverse
j'ai du mal à tout ça donc c'est clair
ça reste des cibles donc
j'aime bien aussi le coup de vent de
Forest qui vous cavalez bien
il replace son cavalier en fait donc
avalait bien oui ben oui il sait que
c'est pas forcément bien dans
l'ouverture mais en fait il s'adapte à
la position donc il a l'idée de
peut-être un jour mettre le pur en
décape pour ouvrir la position mais
aussi maintenant que le cavalier est en
bien enfin dans ces trois j'ai plus
d'avenir du tout ici donc en fait et ben
ils veulent replacer regardez il replace
là pour avoir une meilleure case du coup
derrière
en C4 donc c'est assez c'est assez sympa
ce qui fait en tout cas
et on peut se permettre comme ça de
manorer un peu de reculer les pièces
quand il y a le temps vraiment il faut
que la position s'y prête sinon on évite
quand la position elle est ouverte on
n'a pas le temps parce qu'il y a trop
trop de choses qui peuvent se passer
mais quand la position elle est plus
tranquille
et ben on peut se permettre souvent de
faire ce genre de décision
en tout cas intéressant cette position
j'aime bien les blancs quand même je
peux je fais le direct mais bon ça joue
alors ma méthode on a vu cette position
ou c'est une est indienne à l'envers
c'est destinienne jouer par les Blancs
marrant
avec les Blancs et là c'est génial en
fait le concept
c'est indienne avec un temps de plus
donc écoute ben moi qui attends laisse
indiennes je suis ravi de voir ça donc
H3 oui donc l'idée ça peut être de jouer
F4 un jour
sûrement
et
du coup donc faut prendre F5 par exemple
c'est un coup qui est très très moche
parce qu'en fait après plus on prend et
ben mon fou pourra revivre et sera fort
du coup après faut vérifier si j'ai pas
du yoga mais de toute façon je pense que
c'est pas forcément bon de faire vos
points F5 ça dépend vraiment je pense
que tu arrives à je prise et le 4 ça
peut éventuellement être OK
mais est-ce que tu arrives à jouer le 4
je sais pas
mais bon j'aime pas trop donner ce truc
c'est la seule raison pour moi pourquoi
en fait ça pourrait être possible avec
le fou qui joue avec ce cavalier qui
enfin j'ai deux qui est pas terrible
mais si c'est pas pour manger là il y a
eu à 6 à 5
il faut aussi donc on va se débarrasser
de lui pardon de lui là
pour manger après en A5 je suis quand
même trois fois dessus
sur une deux trois donc si 4 je serai
plus que deux fois dessus donc je
pourrais gagner le pion
comment est-ce que je
comment est-ce qu'on répond pas tout
je cherche
je cherche comment répondre
salut
et plus bouger moyennement fan
ça a du sens
mais normalement si c'est pas bien si je
peux jouer à 5 directs parce que du coup
l'option B est bloqué s'il bouge là j'ai
pris un passant et après j'ai
l'impression là-dessus donc normalement
si à 5 est possible et si ce n'est pas
un bon coup mais si j'arrive à défendre
tu vois il s'en fout complètement
pas de respect
on dit quand il y a un problème
quand il appartient d'un côté on évite
d'en mettre d'autres en prises
donc là il laisse un pion il se dit
carrément non j'en ai rien à faire je
vais je vais rentrer dedans
[Musique]
mais Détroit tu vois ça donne la carte
des cinq aussi
et maintenant part
[Musique]
la pièce qui prend la-bas en fait elle
est perdue elle est perdue en a et là du
coup ça te laisse le temps d'attaquer
même si là j'ai vu le coup qui vient de
faire
que j'aime bien son idée tour à trois
tours j'ai 5 c'est vrai que ça a l'air
quand même pas mal franchement tu auras
trois c'est c'est intéressant très très
fort ça c'est le beau jeu donc ça
s'appelle le transfert ce thème c'est
pas le transfert c'est la tour hyper
loop mais en vrai on a tout à trois
tours J3 c'est l'idée et en fait pour
jouer après j'ai 5 et tout casser et du
coup c'est hyper intéressant alors hyper
fort tu vois il y a il y a
un visage entre la tour et le roi il y a
le fou ce qui attaque là-bas il y a le
cavalier qui est bien placé à F5 le dame
qui peut se changer à tout moment
ça fait très peur
et du coup il a pris il a donné un pur
mais sur 15 mois avant peut-être qu'il
se dit qu'il s'en fout là le temps en
fait voilà comme dit sportif c'est plus
important que le petit pion et je suis
assez d'accord avec lui là maintenant
elle me plaît bien il y a trois coups
donc mais maintenant oui
ok enfin petit tour rapidement
côté blanc donc la paire de fou chez les
noirs
mais une structure un petit peu
chaotique
mais c'est normal quand je la reçois les
mots c'est normal d'avoir sa structure
là
c'est la compensation de la paire de fou
c'est pour ça que les blancs en fait
sacrifie entre guillemets la part de fou
pour provoquer un truc comme ça mais
après ça reste dynamique toujours chez
les Noirs mais les blancs tu vois
stratégiquement au niveau des pions
c'est cool quoi
mais après tu vois je suis pas beaucoup
d'espace mais j'ai pas de faiblesse tu
vois donc on jauge un peu et on voit un
peu ce qui se passe j'aime bien la pause
je vous mets les caméras quand même
shimanov contre
contre jade
jade où elle est Miley
et puis OK en petite cavalier cavalier
voilà
mon stream en fond et dès qu'il voit une
flèche il le fait
et
je pense que
dans son intérêt c'est pas forcément
bien de le faire
non faut pas écouter tout
pas bien un petit peu quand même un
petit peu mais non non
B3 c'est un coup intéressant mais c'est
un con responsable
je suis moyennement fan et je l'ai pas
fait la flèche c'est beau comme
ouais c'est beau mais ça donne des cases
aussi en fait l'idée c'est que on se
défend on sait pas si on joue avec C3 ou
avec B3 et sur ces trois souvent il y a
le pion qui est faible derrière donc
c'est pas forcément l'idée mais
betterons on peut le faire mais en fait
on n'a pas pressé de le faire pour
l'instant mais tu sais que c'est
toujours B3 tu pourras plus jamais jouer
ça parce que du coup tout sera faible tu
vois en général on joue l'un ou l'autre
et
souvent quand tu joues à 5 quand tu vas
jouer à 4 B3 tu as un blocus comme ça
pour avoir le pion à 5 plus tard dans le
viseur mais la B3 je sais pas vraiment
un coup qui était à ce moment là
obligatoire je pense qu'un couple il
faut attendre après je critique
j'aimais bien
j'aime bien aussi qu'il y avait assez
trois
et tu as piqué j'ai trois et quatre
c'est d'ouvrir un peu la base j'en sais
rien en fait mais
[Musique]
je n'aime pas trop mettre trop parce que
je trouve que c'est comique on se
commute un petit peu trop vite par
rapport à la pause je l'aurais pas joué
pas ici
il y a pas le nom des joueurs sur les
sur les tables
à chaque fois ouais on peut le dire à
l'oral alors c'est pas une chinoise
c'est une canadienne qui s'appelle Jade
Wallet Meli
et est-ce qu'on va partir pas sur Carsen
on n'a pas trop vu Carlson en fait c'est
vrai qu'un scène qui a cette finale avec
les Blancs
une grosse avance tout le temps s'il
faut le signaler
carsavik qui est à redoutable en blitz
là de plus en passer c'est beaucoup
beaucoup trop
[Musique]
facile
mais il va manger là il va perdre là et
il va être la tour derrière en gros
et puis elle continue à pousser des
pions et puis si vraiment il a besoin il
sacrifie faire la tour sur le pion pour
continuer à pousser les pions avec son
roi deux pions c'est bon déjà on dit que
depuis la sixième c'est plus fort qu'une
tour là j'ai pas d'option sur la 6e mais
voilà c'est fini juste pour bouge
peut-être tout là mais bon je pense que
je fais juste voilà
j'ai même pas pressé de prendre ça en
fait
5 pions
un petit peu
ouais mais en fait
rien à faire en plus la tour qui défend
là donc du coup s'il veut manger
l'option il faut vraiment qu'il fasse
tout tomber chez qui on a sabanon
s'il avait mangé la tour direct
là bah il y aurait peut-être eu repenser
6 tout simplement et en fait juste je
vais pousser mes pions comme ça pendant
que lui touche les siens je pars par
exemple
allez je fais ça ça je pousse là je
pousse là donc mon roi je pousse je fais
ça bon moment je vais faire tour là puis
je monte mon roi comme ça vous voyez
puis au moment un moment donné
je veux sacrifier ma torche sur le sur
le pion et je vais faire ça et puis ça
et ça en fait vous voyez je suis trop
loin quoi
vous voyez c'est trop vite
donc c'est assez facile cette finale à
gagner donc personne n'a gagné assez
facilement donc 2 sur 2
pour 45 pour l'instant dans ce match
donc on la vente forest contre
costaignan forest qui
qui a une position assez intéressante la
cata qui sont le roi direct et aussi un
problème sur le roi blanc mais ça a
l'air d'avoir
trois quatre un peu plus pour les blancs
quand même avec une belle attaque G4 qui
est très fort qui défend tout qui a à la
fois défend le roi blanc mais en même
temps attaque aussi avec F6 dame 4 le
carré noir qui a pas de cases
quand même
ça va être perdu et ventes Forest en
plus qui est capable dans son élément la
position assez actif comme ça c'est
vraiment ce qu'il aime
et
nul doute qui va gagner cette partie et
du coup ça mettrait bien
ça la mettrait bien les les chaises bras
dans ce match avec les deux leaders de
l'équipe qui sont à deux sur deux pour
l'instant
du coup avec l'impression qu'on avait
dit avant donc j'ai vu un il y a un coup
il avait tout rage 3 G5 MG4 j'aime bien
cette position
il envoie la maison là il envoie la
maison et tout aussi on prend il se
passe quoi H7 non
prise abandon ouais j'ai trop de jeu
quoi tu as un énorme partie de ma vie de
la fin franchement ma méthode
impressionnante cette partie hyper
impressionnant
alors on peut aller voir un petit peu le
score
de la part de vent de Forest et dans la
dernière partie du coup de ce de ce
set et ben on a encore shimanof avec les
Blancs ici contre jade donc une partie
encore beaucoup de pièces sur
l'échiquier
ah mais là c'est le temps qui
peut faire mal
donc elle est mal autant
et en plus ça peut être
plus pour les blancs
donc si tu prends là ça remet quand même
la structure on n'a pas trop envie de
manger quand même
bah il lui faut à trois quand même qui
peut être intéressant pour ouvrir ce fou
aussi
ce qu'elle est pas très bien placé pour
l'instant comment est-ce que je pourrais
le remplacer ce cavalier
est-ce que X A3 D4 enfin c'est 4 D4
idée d'essayer de mettre ce cavalier un
jour en C5
noir
sur la couleur un verre ce foulard
où est-ce qu'on joue
il faut emprise
en fait le cavalier étape il tape sur 5
on est peut-être pas pressé de manœuvrer
parce que les noirs sont aussi donc
c'est resté à la dépense elle est pas
vraiment emprise si tu prends j'ai quand
même prendre ses 5 et comme un clouage
ok je suis pas femme mais
là on va essayer de s'activer je sais
pas comment on s'active
est-ce que
je n'ai pas vu
quand tu manges là je mange là
un petit peu toutes les pièces
même comme ça ça l'a bien pour les noirs
pour les blancs quand même parce que tu
vois sur ça
ça ça il y a quand même des problèmes
dans la position des noirs et tu
n'arriveras pas à faire à faire ça j'ai
toujours la première 4 même si cela est
pas mal ouais
55 secondes pour shimanov avec les
Blancs
contre contre 12 seulement pour pour
Jade
qui bouge tu vas se remettre sur une
belle case peut-être cavaler ces trois
recettes c'est une erreur à cause de
et surprise là je prends là tu vois donc
ça serait l'erreur et c'est 5 peut-être
dans l'idée
de faire attention
c'est pas si facile franchement
c'est moi ou ça a été joué tempo
et c'est chaud cette position parce que
prise attention
en vrai ça fait un peu peur
du coup
fk3 là j'aime bien ouais très bien ça
empêche le roi de venir ici
le Roi peut juste pas venir
comment on finit
bloquer mais c'est gagnant
du coup faut au 4 bien joué il y a eu 4
qui va arriver
à 3
ça a été raté
c'est pas fini
il faut cliquer là
mais il est pas content on a le score on
a le score mais du coup la fin de partie
une déconnexion à deux secondes
peut-être
quel dommage
il a gagné autant quel dommage reste
abandon
c'est fini incroyable qui avait les
bouches d'âme
incroyable elle a fait une super partie
jade elle aurait clairement cette
victoire du coup ça refait de deux dans
ce match ça n'aurait pu regarder son
équipe avec 3 1 3 1 ça aurait été
écrasant à bord de cette Fatou avec deux
points d'avance avec en plus un gain de
jade contre un joueur à 2600 hello ça
aurait été monstrueux
en fait
tous donc c'est plus facile pour lui de
gagner mais en revanche pour elle du
coup c'est c'est plus compliqué donc de
faire ne serait-ce qu'une victoire ça ça
peut mettre l'équipe très très bien
dommage
en fait
de finir par craquer même si c'est au
moment peut-être le plus frustrant parce
que justement
mais elle a fait une grosse grosse
partie c'est dommage ça peut pas être
que ça pas payant tout ça
alors qu'on doit 3 juste je vais mettre
des appariements
du coup on va avoir
shimanov qui vient de gagner au temps
avec les dents
contre
Magnus cars scène
qui aura les noirs
au deuxième on va avoir du coup
[Musique]
Raouf ma méthode d'une super partie avec
la standienne franchement monstrueuse
dans son style dans ses ouvertures je
vois beaucoup de parties de lui quand je
me prépare quand je regarde tout ça il
est vraiment génial j'aime beaucoup
comme genre
ça m'intéresse est-ce que vous avez des
modèles est-ce que vous avez des joueurs
que vous préférez des gens donc vous
aimez bien avoir les parties ou des
joueurs avec lesquels vous vous inspirez
quand vous vous voyez des ouvertures
quand vous préparez moi j'en ai plein au
niveau des styles de jeu aussi beaucoup
trouve pas la beauté des échecs tous
partout dans les réparties
alors après autour
c'est pas bien moi je voudrais savoir
cliquer comme
je t'apprendrai un jour merci
sérieuse dans le
Fisher
après et ça c'est ça ça c'est des gens
qui sont tellement forts vous voyez ils
ont des styles un peu universel
donc c'est
mais moi par exemple dans en tant que
joueur qui sont très très bon mais pas
l'évite mondial par exemple ma médof
j'aime beaucoup
c'est une offre aussi j'aime bien tous
les jours en fait qui par rapport à des
styles tu vois même par exemple James
Goren j'aime beaucoup aussi
il y avait aussi comment il s'appelait
sont deux frères
sont deux frères de Biélorussie
2006 2600
je sais plus comment il s'appelle
[Musique]
souvent si tu veux c'est par rapport aux
ouvertures que quand tu prépares un truc
tu vois des parties de ces mecs là tu
dis en fait les mecs ils sont forts quoi
après il y a un autre mec comme ça aussi
qui est que moi j'aime beaucoup son
style c'est bon en fait c'est l'école
c'est un petit peu si tu veux à l'école
chez balenco avec par exemple il y a
beau Logan
il y a aussi alors que j'aime beaucoup
c'est nevenici mais ça c'est des joueurs
que vous connaissez pas je pense 2500 à
l'eau mais en fait c'est des joueurs un
peu plus modeste qui sont très très
forts et dans le style en fait moi ça me
trouve très bien quoi et aussi un jour
que j'aime beaucoup c'est c'est le
joueur du Pérou
c'était Grinda zuliga tu vois genre à
2650 2007 qui en fait sont des grosses
grosses machines dans leur style mais
c'est les gens qui sont beaucoup moins
connus si vous voulez
beaucoup moins connu
parce que du coup du coup voilà quoi
alors tu l'as battu quand même je sais
que tu l'as joué encore
et je sais que tu es pas tu as pas duré
longtemps sur ta chaise donc que tu les
battues j'ai un petit doute mais
je dirais rien mais je me souviens que
Star dragon
et que ta partie
ta partie ah junior tu as pas tu la
fille ah oui bon ok
excuse-moi
2 secondes pour répondre au chat de
YouTube donc il y a Léo qui demande si
le match de Magnus est passé
donc pour cette randou oui c'est fini
mais évidemment il rejoue il joue les
quatre rondins chaque chaque joueur donc
on alterne un petit peu on regarde un
peu tous les matchs du coup on va revoir
Magnus sur moi-même commencer par lui au
match suivant et
calice effectivement c'est terrible de
perdre autant je pense que c'est le pire
et surtout quand on est très gagnant
c'est le moyen de bien tilter et bien
frustré je pense que ça nous est tous
arrivé faire des parties gagnantes et
puis perdre autant
ça fait mal toi c'était jamais arrivé
perdre autant non mais perdre des
parties gagnantes
tu perds et tu finis par gagner arnaque
à son style on parlait de style moi je
suis pas des chèques moi je joue
ce qui se passe mais non non moi je suis
pas un genre d'échec moi je suis pas une
référence les gars
un coup
tu m'as compris quoi donc
écoutez
vous savez que je blague tous ceux qui
t'ont pris comme modèle là ils vont vite
changer d'avis
c'est différent
de l'adversaire comme toi
c'est un peu l'inverse quand je suis
perdant je flag et je ne perds pas par
contre quand je suis archi gagnant mais
alors là c'est
c'est dur
les gars j'en profite pour vous annoncer
qu'à la fin de ce stream et ben je vais
me faire un petit raid à ma chaîne sur
ma chaîne et je partirai sur un petit
stream sur ma chaîne
donc ça sera à la fin de ce match donc
je pense sur les alentours de
19 heures
19h30 à peu près voilà
ça peut se retourner
[Musique]
ça va être chaud encore on verra bien
mais dans tous les cas dans tous les cas
[Musique]
ouais à la fin de ce stream là on
partira sur ma chaîne avec un petit raid
je me ferai le raid tout seul et je le
remercierai d'ailleurs
je remercierai c'est important il faut
être poli avec les gens ah oui
vite sur ta chaîne dire merci à tous
merci beaucoup
t'inquiète je sais pas qui se cache
derrière le pseudo
3 là qui est sorti comme ça arrive un
petit peu
vous me dites d'accord à tout de suite
j'arrive
à très bientôt
pas très professionnel on note que moi
j'ai pris à boire avant de venir alors
que souffre non
pas très sérieux le coiffeur de capsen a
pris après combien de temps en prison
non mais pourquoi vous aimez pas ses
cheveux longs ils sont bien
on avait dit on avait dit plus tard
non mais ils sont bien ses cheveux par
contre je crois vraiment qu'il y a les
doucher entre la première et la deuxième
ronde qui est très drôle sachant qu'il
est revenu en plus en mangeant à la
deuxième ronde
on voit bien qu'ils sont chez eux ils
sont tranquilles les joueurs ils sont
vraiment tranquilles
je sais du coup j'ai aucune j'ai aucune
vue moi sur si ça commence ou pas parce
que c'est tout ce qui est là la main et
les réglages
les femmes sont plus prévoyantes
semble-t-il et pourtant et pourtant on
sait que tout figure la technique du
coup donc il était il était prêt il
était près de 15 minutes avant moi même
il a fait tous les réglages et devant
son ordi mais il a pas pris de
en fait tous des erreurs
se nourrir des chèques mais non
manque plus que l'eau
ma vie de souffle
qui perd tout le temps mais on perd tous
beaucoup faut pas s'inquiéter alors tout
le temps heureusement non personne ne
perd tout le temps et il faut bien juste
équilibre et des gens qui perdent c'est
comme ça
salut salut
comment ça va
préférer leur lit avant de passer à la
TV ouais ouais c'est vrai mais tu vois
ça ça renforce le côté
côté naturel
ils sont comme ils sont
mais bon c'est sûr que
j'aurais pu faire un petit effort quand
même là
on soupçonne que tu ne sois pas allé
voir de l'eau
[Musique]
ne fassent pas leur lit
je suis d'accord
terminé non non il rejoue là c'est la
troisième ronde qui démarre est-ce que
ça a démarré d'ailleurs
très très équilibré et d'ailleurs il y
aura forcément quatre rondes parce qu'il
faut être Huit et demi pour qualifier
avant la quatrième ronde et là forcément
c'est pas possible
donc donc c'est bien ça va durer on va
voir même si ça va durer encore plus
longtemps que prévu qui c'est
une caméra qui fait de sauter chez je
crois que c'est la caméra de lazaville
non c'est qui c'est lui qui avait un
problème attends
[Musique]
on le voit pas enfin moi je le vois pas
je vous le dis
ouh là là ça c'est pour ça
c'est pour
ah non pardon c'est D4 direct non je te
dis n'importe quoi
OK
c'est original j'imagine que si ma mère
a ses propres idées dans l'ouverture
voir un petit peu
ce qui me fait
moi j'aime bien les Noirs déjà c'est une
position standard et ses pièces souvent
sont mal placé on va voir un petit peu
ok petit tour rapide
je vais pouvoir l'ouverture tiens
Espagne
alors ça je le joue avec les blancs des
fois il y a plein de couilles
voilà bon
il avait le petit rock en fait il y a
plusieurs coups il y avait un coup
marrant ici à la place je crois que
c'est fou ces quatre et sur cavalier
prend F3 il y a un super couple à tous
c'est
avec tour géant c'est une ligne qui a
une popularisé ici est une Bacro avec
Sébastien Mazet voilà il savait de ça
pas mal travaillé ça et c'était une
ligne qui était vraiment intéressante
pour pour les blancs marrant je vais
prendre froid
qui contredit les principes d'ouverture
qui n'est pas intuitif mais voilà quand
c'est travailler c'est vraiment
travailler et abouti
donc à ce moment là ça peut jouer et
regarde votre forest qui joue une file
d'or avec les Noirs il a échangé un
cavalier contre le fou blanc et je me
suis mis dehors c'est pas merveilleuse
parce que c'est pas merveilleux en fait
il a mangé la paire de fou et une fille
dehors en fait c'est un génie avant toi
c'est un grand génie quoi il a tout
compris
mettre la vidéo sauf que
sur la caméra elle n'est pas là donc la
vidéo ne marche pas
alors si on part tableau 3 du coup un
petit préau tout qui est à moitié sur la
caméra parce que du coup ben écoutez
c'est à cause de Forest encore une fois
qu'il est pas là et ça c'est encore une
fois une position qui ressemble un petit
peu à une est indienne au final bon
c'était c'était pas et tout ça regardez
j'ai trois
et au final
blanc et je vous laisse
trois tours
standard et tout tape sur le 5
là je sais pas comment on doit jouer
souvent
des cases à l'adversaire
le fou
mais bon C4 aussi pour taper sur le pion
de 5
ok bon bah c'est une partie quoi c'est
une partie et la dernière du coup c'est
parti
c'est juste pour dire en fait que c'est
une position un peu bizarre
qu'on ne connaît pas bien mais que ça
joue quoi pas de la manière de dire ça
et
du coup
du coup ici cavaler ses 6 ok
E4 voilà je mets bien 4 prise cavaler
prend
et puis bon c'est une partie Fatou
franchement il y a aucun doute là-dessus
que j'aime bien pour les blancs
tout un peu ouvert c'est
assez chiant excuse-moi papa
je pense qu'il faut manger
pas forcément content de manger en fait
on n'aime pas garder un les pions
et il faut y aller
après c'est trop tard on peut pas
laisser l'adversaire s'installer au
centre
tranquillement
de côté j'aime pas parce que
généralement quand on joue quand on joue
sur deux coups bah il faut pas que le
centre soit ouvert donc quand on est
ouvert souvent c'est que qui est une
tension en fait sur le centre et là du
coup on peut tout manger et les pions
faibles ici donc c'est pas facile à
jouer comme comme coup tu vois c'est
comme dans l'étend dernier quand tu
joues F5 généralement tu peux pas le
jouer F5
si il y a une tension en fait au centre
mais une fois que l'agent est fermé F5
c'est un coup normal dans la tarzième
c'est alors pour ça qu'ici le 5 c'est un
coup qui
m'a l'air bizarre vers ça a été joué
mais
je m'en sens je me sentir un petit peu
obligé
je pense qu'il était pas forcément ravi
de 5 mais si tu prends tu as des
problèmes sur les cases blanches si tu
fais rien je fais le 5
et donc à un moment donné il faut
empêcher 5 ou tu vois donc du coup il
prend le centre mais maintenant ce qu'il
faut voir c'est est-ce que du coup je
peux essayer de manger du style je mange
là tu manges là je mange là tu manges là
il lui cavaler ses cadres tu as bon il
faut regarder quoi tu vois mais bon
c'est pas clair là j'ai quand même suivi
de 4 qui est l'arcade intéressante aussi
donc avoir mais ça ça a l'air pas mal
elle est là et qui aime découverte
derrière sur la tour
tu vois là je commence à trouver que les
les noirs sont quand même pas mal
ça peut vite tourner
à sa forte
ouais bon en tout cas intéressant comme
pose E5 c'est le coup en fait qui est
l'agent par défaut je pense voilà alors
qui a cette pause ok bah écoute c'est
pas mal cette histoire
tu penses que ça joue Fatou
moi je dirais que c'est une partie
du coup OK
alors c'est pas un coup pour l'instant
un manque 6 ça a un coup c'est 4 je peux
le jouer
je fais échec au roi et je mange ton
cavalier
et si tu manges ici intermédiaire bah je
prends et je défends en fait du coup ça
va bien
parce que je le pense
ça va partir il y a eu tout ça
et ben écoute j'aime bien les blancs
on a même une idée regarde
d'un échec qui peut arriver avec roi
bouge G4 qui fait très très peur
et puis il y a aussi un autre coup qui
est standard dans cette position c'est
échec celui de cavaler les dessins puis
on prend puis on prend il y a un clouage
à son cavalier on peut récupérer le
Caval comme ça c'était mati qui a un
dans toutes ces positions de sicilienne
un petit peu tous vu ça
donc moi j'aime beaucoup les blancs les
garsun je trouve qu'il y a une position
qui a dure à faire la jauge on voit
qu'elle est
elle est toujours vers la qualité alors
E5
c'est un coup qui est dégueulasse
je vais pas laisser ton cavalier
à passer par G4
qui est complètement ouverte donc en
fait il fait ça qu'il a ferme mais pour
que cartel joue un truc comme ça c'est
que vraiment il considère que la
position elle est elle va pas du tout
sinon j'aurais jamais joué donc c'est
dégueulasse parce que bon vous voyez ça
donne la case des cinq gratuitement ça
affaiblit toute la production etc
mais d'un autre côté il faut pas trouver
une solution sur la menace qu'on avait
évoqué avant avec Dan b2kvg4 donc du
coup c'est un coup qui fait sens par
rapport au
de la position mais si il arrive à jouer
à jouer 5 c'est parce que vraiment la
pollution elle
est après d'un autre côté il a aussi la
case des câbles donc bon
tu vois
même si la position elle est compliquée
même si la jauge elle monte tout en haut
en pratique ça reste encore pas simple
il y a plein de de de
de
[Musique]
il y a plein de
choix à faire d'améliorer j'aime bien
ouais
[Musique]
enfermer un peu la tour mais il faut
voir si vraiment tout reprend cavalier
est une menace imaginons je passe mon
tour juste pour caricaturer je monte ça
là moins de sens parce que du coup le
cavalier ici peut plus venir là en fait
et du coup bah j'ai toujours du jeu mais
c'est pas forcément clair
alors si je mange un pion peut-être
c'est mieux pour ouvrir la position moi
j'aime bien reprendre d'ailleurs
maintenant ouvre mais
ça ferme quand même des faiblesse
on voit la jauge qui qui aime bien ce
que je propose
et celui-là j'aime moins parce que ce
fouille mal placé oui en fait ce fou il
est malheureux donc il faut l'ouvrir
l'ordinateur parce qu'il y a une ligne
pour les blancs et voir ce que c'était
en fait
non mais ça m'intéresse je vois pourquoi
ok tu vois il pouvait en fait obtenir la
potion qu'on voulait en fait il a fait
un B2 en se disant bah s'il y en a je
bouffe tu vois parce que là échec et là
je rentre de partout que mon cavalier
c'est c'est la boucherie
et du coup karacène mais il est pas bête
il a fait faux aussi pour faire et une
fois que je vous fais cavalier peut-être
mettre le camion des 4 et maintenant tu
auras plus les cavaliers F6 avant et du
coup il aurait pu faire à l'envers tu
vois ça qui est beau en fait B5 qui
force le cavalent des cartes pour ça que
tu es venu là je mange et maintenant je
fais ça
je fais B6 casse-toi et je prends la
quoi
ok c'est fort ça a été raté par par
shimanov généralement en fait on essaie
de construire souvent ce qui manque
aussi aux débutants c'est de construire
un peu son jeu et là pour le coup c'est
ce qu'il a fait il a voulu préparer
préparer vraiment en fait non fallait
être direct donc après ça maintenant en
partie en partie officielle il n'aurait
jamais raté
là on est en blitz du contre Carcassonne
bon il y a plein de facteurs qui fait
que il a pas vu ça
mais voilà est-ce qu'il va manger où
vous avez la qualité
j'aime bien par contre j'aurais plutôt
manger de l'option quand même tout à
l'heure pour montrer
mais en fait j'aime pas ce qu'il a fait
c'est pas bien
là par exemple comme tout à l'heure on
avait dit c'est 5 et ben après puis on
prend et ben si tu veux j'ai plus le B
prend comme j'avais dit
donc
B5 maintenant je suis moins fan
peut-être j'ai trop à Fougères c'est
intéressant aussi
OK
bon
[Musique]
je vais enlever ça
ma roi bouge je pense et Tours C8 on va
changer les pièces bon ça reste pas
simple parce que c'est vrai que si je
fais 5 un jour je peux je peux échanger
ça comme ça de créer un prêt passé je
fous qui peut être fort sur le premier 7
bon il y a toujours un peu de jeu mais
c'est vrai que si ils ont arrivés avec
torse 8 ramener les tours un peu comme
ça la dame bon je peux passer par
derrière un peu c'est de gagner là
de réfléchir au plan réellement
donc on prépare
prépare en fait la finale par
tranquillement on réfléchit bien on va
recommencer
des fois il peut y avoir
même si je suis pas sûr
genre ça ça je viens ici
et là en plus après tu vois j'ai du
genre E5 puis on prend il faut prendre
puis on prend
le tomate
le jeu des blancs c'est
essayer de faire nul ou faire quelque
chose avec le pion des c'est de le faire
en tout cas il faut être actif si je
suis pas actif et Ben et ben c'est perdu
c'est très important
es
la protection pour se dire qu'on va
peut-être faire quelque chose après
c'est un couche chacun son tour donc les
Noirs jouent ils ont tant de
tu savais pas non non
un petit peu ailleurs parce que ça fait
un petit moment qu'on y est là allons
voir ailleurs
non mais après je peux juste là il y a
même bêtises
je sais pas je joue
je pensais aussi tout à l'heure pour
vraiment prise prise et tout ouvrir et
ça m'avait un peu trop grand bol mais ok
tout droit il reste dans l'idée de faire
ressort aussi un jour c'est chaud en
pratiquant franchement même pour moi
pour se défendre là il faut
il faut
[Musique]
faut s'accrocher là pour ces deux
et dans ma tête
est-ce que j'arrive c'est pas grave tu
vas manœuvrer
une question
ça serait beau quand même on va pas
avoir les autres il y a déjà eu match
nul on n'a pas vu la nulle
la nul de on peut le voir rapidement si
vous voulez la nul 2 de fin de Forest
contre mohamedov donc après c'est une
fille là
et il a donné
tout ça ok
bon ben écoute c'est pas de fou
ont du mal à s'exprimer dans cette
position
il a fait son taf
bon ok pourquoi pas
3 4 5 6 7 ok bon
à côté
j'ai un peu peur
[Musique]
un peu faibles tu vois un jour peut-être
que si jamais les pièces siègent un
petit peu je peux passer par là c'est le
manger les pions je suis pas fan de la
potion blanche même si c'est pas clair
mais d'accord
précis et bon ouais en fait c'est
vachement avancer des pions donc c'est
un peu comique tu vois
et là c'est instinct de dire un peu
typique où les blancs prennent tout
l'espace à la dame et sur mater elle a
le droit donc là il va falloir là ça va
être chaud
après il faut que je sens qu'il
chaud la prise est prise c'est perdu
comment tu défends ça parce que si tu
bouges le fou
je mange là je mange là
je mange là
je ferai ça c'est chaud mais par exemple
c'est chaud pour les problèmes
que j'avais pas vu 4
ouais
en pratique c'est tellement dur pour les
blancs ils ont 20 secondes de la pendule
contre 3 minutes je pense que ça va
perdre on va voir grâce à si tu veux
quelqu'un qui est un peu danger quand
même
cette partie
c'est quand la plus importante la partie
donc un autre ou trois cas donc il a
réussi à défendre comment il a fait
rapidement pour qu'on revienne en direct
ah il a fait torcer
on est bon les gars
est-ce qu'on est bon franchement tout
était prévu et franchement on se gave
c'est ce qu'on est fort
il y a plus trop d'attaque ou pas
aussi c'est toujours
après après il y a la dame pour défendre
on est là on est dans cet affaire
et on voit et tu peux pas jouer avec
dame dans ma chatte
il y a eu des couleurs
les gars on trouve tous les coups
on trouve tous les coups trop fort
[Musique]
alors j'ai une idée marlou c'est ça
pour jouer ça et ça
mais bon on pourrait d'activer ta tour
de ça en fait c'est mat
si tu manges là c'est quoi le souci
on va le voir
c'est replay ou c'est tout machin il
veut faire que ça
on est solide
ça a été joué B6 pour C7 ouais c'est
ultra chaud il y a 10 secondes chacun
qui est qui est
[Musique]
j'avais pas vu le temps
on voit le score malheureusement
un peu deg de le voir
le score
je regrette d'avoir regardé j'avais pas
regardé
j'ai vu partir je me suis dit bon
et
non franchement grosse partie en tout
cas shimanov qui est venu mater
qui qui devait perdre contre Jade
et qui battent derrière quoi enfin
de l'impossible bah soit tu
culpabilise de ton aide-sortie alors que
tu aurais peut-être pas dû ou soit tu te
rebooste à fond et tu enchaîne non mais
il est il est très dangereux
c'est clair
donc alors il y a encore une partie là
du coup prêt au tout doit gagner pour
son équipe et il est mal il est malade
j'avais vu le score cancer mais là
j'avais pas vu pour cela
et c'est abondant donc 3 et demi sur 4
ouh là là c'est très très chaud ce qui
veut dire que du coup après cette ronde
après cette manche et ben là le
obligation obligation absolue de faire
au moins au moins trois et demi
au moins 3 et demi pour 4 scène ce qui
veut dire que
jade
bon déjà parce que c'est la moins forte
de l'équipe mais elle peut pas perdre en
fait la moindre partie la moindre partie
perdue dans le quatrième set et ben la
moindre partie perdue et Ben et ben ça
va être ça va être fini quoi
ça va être fini c'est dommage ça se
jouer ça se jouer là ils prennent la
tête au bon moment
ouais mais tu vois tu vois c'est c'est
vraiment ce qu'on me disait depuis un
truc moi je dis depuis le début de la
prothèse League en fait l'équipe elle
est pour de personnes elle est très
forte on a 45 qui qui monstrueux on a
avant de Forest qui a des meilleurs
joueurs du monde aussi on a un 2500 qui
est assez bon aussi envie c'est rapide
bon même si pour l'instant il est à 0.3
c'est quand même un bon joueur et une
fille à 2002 derrière et en fait
moi je pensais à l'équipe chinoise où
ils avaient why devant et après ils
avaient trois jours à 2500 Hello
et en fait et en fait du coup je pense
que quand une équipe plus compact tu
vois au final ben c'est cool ça imagine
en fait
imagine dans le meilleur des mondes cars
scène et Van forest gagne tout leur
match tu vois
et derrière ben c'est vrai quand même
que que il est quand même moins fort un
peu que tous les jours adverse bah j'ai
l'impression en fait que si tu veux pour
que
le score soit équilibré tu es obligé
d'avoir quelqu'un qui marque les points
en fait
ils ont pas le droit à l'erreur
t'as pas trop le droit non plus à
l'erreur
compression pour les premières tables et
là on l'a vu juste avant ça se joue à
rien et ceux qui peuvent faire la
différence comme Jade
à la ronde précédente c'est ça ça vaut
pour beaucoup parce que c'est
l'impression que dès que Carlson en fait
gagne pas sa partie et ben l'équipe elle
a la rue parce qu'en fait tout
simplement
tout simplement c'est
[Musique]
c'est trop dur derrière en fait tu vois
donc ouais
donc la 3 points de nuit zéro et demi
c'est la fessée comme dirait robinside
et là il faut une réaction de suite la 3
et demi minimum pour pour les bras mais
ça m'a l'air difficile
pour gagner de match déjà donc
du coup
je vais vous mettre dans un pariments du
coup de de la dernière ronde le sexe
[Musique]
en même temps pour répondre aux
questions allez vas-y je te laisse
pendant que mes appareils
des nouvelles ouvertures tu sais à mes
mises en avant en parler dans
l'ouverture tout à l'heure avec la prise
en F3 et l'arrivée de la tour en géant
je sais pas si tu vois à ce moment là il
y a la question de savoir si ils
utilisaient les ordis ou pas pour pour
travailler travailler l'option comme ça
[Musique]
mais en fait c'est intéressant
des variantes des sous variantes pour
essayer de
un peu plus de fun aussi dans les échecs
plutôt que de toujours répéter les mêmes
choses on aime quand il y a des idées
comme ça qui naissent des trucs un peu
aussi le fait d'essayer d'avoir un
avantage à l'ouverture le fait d'essayer
de de surprendre l'adversaire dans la
partie c'est bien d'avoir aussi des
surprises tu vois des nouvelles choses
travaillées que toi tu connais très bien
et quand tu prends un adversaire qui ne
connaît pas bah tu peux vraiment
le surprendre et prendre un bel avantage
quoi dans l'ouverture c'est parti de ça
aussi tu vois les travailles dans les
ouvertures c'est important
bien sûr après
au niveau même très très haut niveau
j'allais stipuler ça bien sûr les
ouvertures si vous si vous avez 800 élo
sur le diascom n'allez pas travailler 30
coups de théorique
par contre là à ce niveau là
à ce niveau là c'est normal 2700 elle
aussi leur métier quand c'est votre
métier il faut bosser quoi il faut voilà
c'est vrai
ok moi j'ai mis des caméras je suis prêt
une deuxième question aussi commentaire
sur sur Youtube de Kalys qu'est-ce qui
est une cadence reconnue comme la plus
équitable aux échecs je suis néophyte et
nulle aussi mais 10 minutes par exemple
ça ne permet pas de jouer aux échecs
j'ai l'impression
bon ça dépend ce que tu fais mais c'est
vrai que les les gros tournois
[Musique]
officiel quoi
avec 1h30 + 30 secondes parcours et
souvent aussi un rajout de temps 40e
coup donc il y a souvent les ventes
comme ça mais c'est les parties lente
ouais le
on va mettre ça entre guillemets mais
les vrais échecs où tu te casses la tête
ou tu prends la tête sur les coups tu
prends ton temps pour réfléchir c'est un
peu la recherche de la perfection
quelque part ou de la vérité dans dans
le jeu donc
c'est plus intéressant
après c'est plus intéressant oui non
parce qu'il y en a qui s'intéresse pas
du tout
chaque cadence a c'est assez spécificité
mais c'est vrai que il y a plus
facilement des
erreurs aussi remplies ou en rapide
comme ici parce que
on n'a pas le temps à ce que tu disais
je trouve tout à l'heure il y a un coup
qui a été qui a été loupé mais en l'an
en an il l'aurait vu il aurait dû sans
problème
c'est clair après voilà pour le pour le
spectacle pour le string pour tout ça
c'est vrai que les cadences plus rapides
c'est ce qui est mieux parce que du coup
si tu vois si on commande tout ça en
même temps avec des cadences très très
longues bon on le fait souvent pour
plein d'événements mais c'est vrai que
le public si tu veux et bah ils sont
ennuient vite en fait donc du coup c'est
vrai que toutes ces cadences rapides
tout ce qu'on fait sur Internet aussi et
en fait les gens même vous qui êtes sur
Youtube ou sur twitch et ben en tant que
spectateur c'est quand même plus sympa
de voir ça et de voir des erreurs et de
voir que qu'il y a qu'un scène qui donne
une pièce ou qui sont matés plutôt que
de voir une partie qui dure 7 heures
pour faire nul quoi
ce qui est généralement
mais mais par exemple voyez très souvent
en fait normalement aux échecs si les
deux joueurs jouent à la perfection et
ben la fin ça fait nul quoi et du coup
dans une partie de fin dans un tournoi
de très très haut niveau généralement
sur je sais pas 10 parties tu en as au
moins 8 qui font nuls quoi généralement
et donc du coup pas très souvent enfin 8
minimum vaut même plus deux fois moins
ça dépend mais c'est vrai du coup que
voilà le Blitz partir rapide tout ça
c'est plus spectaculaire et c'est plus
pour le grand public c'est plus pour
pour tous ces commentaires là etc mais
c'est pas des vrais échecs les vrais
échecs c'est vraiment
plutôt voilà les cadenceslandes etc donc
voilà après il y a un peu de tout pour
le débutant oui il vaut mieux jouer des
cadences plus longues on attend
réfléchir de prendre son temps de bien
par faire d'erreur et essayer de
progresser quoi
commence par le lent pour justement en
fait il faut il faut réfléchir mais ça
marche ça marche comme ça enfin ça
marche à l'école aussi il faut passer du
temps sur sur une activité pour après
pour la faire rapidement donc ceux qui
commencent par le
Blitz rapide ou même le Bullet c'est pas
la même chose que quelqu'un qui va
commencer par par le lent par faire
faire des fiches d'exercices passer 10
20 minutes sur un seul exercice ou
vraiment on
pose son cerveau sur la table et c'est
comme ça en passant du temps et c'est
chronophage les échecs mais il faut
passer du temps pour après à créer
acquérir des automatismes et pouvoir et
pouvoir jouer plus intelligemment plus
facilement et mieux dans des cadences
rapides donc normalement
il faut passer par le lent pour espérer
pour espérer aussi s'améliorer dans les
cadences plus rapides
vous pouvez
jouer aux échecs réfléchir etc plutôt
que de jouer des cadence trop rapide ou
ça va trop vite et puis et puis c'est
juste
voilà
donc du coup on a 45 contre ma Madoff ça
a commencé personne qui joue qui joue
toute son gâteau
et
du coup bah je pense qu'ils les joueurs
savent que
que
le match est plié
les blancs forest les blancs
[Musique]
c'est un flippant c'est 55 ans ok il
gagne
bah ok après il reste Jade et qui doit
essayer de pas perdre la baignoire bon
que la deuxième partie elle a failli
maintenant tu vois que ça s'il y avait
eu 5,5 aime pas la même
donc là je crois que la Lune c'est
cavaliers là je crois que c'est un truc
il me semble
c'est pas si j'ai des bêtises ou pas
[Musique]
c'est une partie tranquille avant de
Forest qu'est-ce qu'il nous fait c'est
une karaoka avec C4 ok donc avec H4 H5
donc c'est chaude on forest qui prend un
peu tous les tous les risques pour
essayer de gagner la partie
laser
ah c'est une
comment ça s'appelle
le gars dans le chat là
[Musique]
j'aurais pu j'aurais pu le lire pour toi
oui mais
merci à eux de nuit mon ami mon ami de
de Fréjus
je connais tout le monde dans le chat
il y a plein de trucs possibles mais
c'est une ouverture qui est quand même
réputée pour être
incorrect un petit torture avec le noir
et morose
mais ce que j'aime beaucoup avec avec
mon rosélix à l'époque c'est que tout ce
qui était censé être
pas bon ou réfuter
et il gagne tu vois et c'est un génie
quoi
ça c'est facile
en fait c'est
tu sais que c'est bon mais tu sais pas
pourquoi donc ça en fait il a des idées
tu vois là regarde la potion typique il
est blanc on le centre et la paire de
fou
tu vois
donc
[Musique]
le centre par défaut tu te dis bah non
c'est pas bon pour les Noirs enfin tu
vois mais bon le roi blanc il ressent
entre tu vois c'est c'est des positions
si tu veux qui sont
qui sont quatre déséquilibrés quoi donc
tu peux pas dire enfin bien sûr les
blancs sont mieux mais ça
c'est parti
et non mais c'est clair que c'est clair
que c'est mieux mais tu vois regarde je
peux toujours manger là manger à H2
droit est au centre voilà ça reste
compliqué mais c'est vrai que bon c'est
quand même un avantage blanc ici
par exemple
alors
j'avais vu une alapine de costaignan
contre Salem Saleh lors d'un match
précédent elle avait maté Salem au
centre de l'échiquier avec son roi donc
ça allait me saler c'est un joueur à
2700 hello quasiment donc bon elle
connaît bien la Lapina
ça c'est clair que c'est pas
ok donc tout ça
[Musique]
bon je connais pas bien parce que là
mais c'est une position cool pour les
blancs tu vois
avoir un peu mais si un joueur de
l'équipe de de l'éditeur chess Wizard
gagne une partie c'est terminé si un
jour fait une nul ils sont sur au moins
des partages à deux petites nuits ça va
vite
victoire peut-être
un peu claqué
en fait il y a tellement de lignes pour
avoir un avantage blanc dans la
figurine c'est trop dur parce que tu
peux le sculux mais
[Musique]
même si je connais pas en fait je me
retrouve jamais mal en fait à part si je
peux pas vraiment bien d'ouverture quoi
mais la chicorne c'est une ouverture qui
était pas mal à l'époque quand c'était
pas trop étudié maintenant à tous les
ordismes mais c'est même pas la peine
juste tu joues pas quoi tu la ranges
dans la petite gorille
malheureusement bah c'est c'est un des
avantages inconvénients de l'ordinateur
tu vas l'ordinateur bah il fait que
maintenant il y a beaucoup plus de
lumière qu'on apprend tu vois qu'avant
avant il y a plus de place à la
créativité des ouvertures le fait de pas
connaître les ouvertures et vos échecs
et maintenant ben
un avantage aussi
notre niveau d'échec à grandement
évolué grâce au silordinateur parce que
du coup on a plus de connaissances tu
vois dans un peu de partout mais d'un
autre côté il y a moins de créativité
maintenant parce que tout se fait
avec l'ordi quoi donc c'est bon ça va un
petit peu ce que tu dis avec un
décorateur de YouTube parce
qu'effectivement maintenant il y a
beaucoup de Parker on apprend par coeur
on respecte en fait et c'est vrai qu'on
perd
perdre un peu de beauté du jeu quelque
part alors après ce qui ce
qui nous rassure c'est un petit peu
aussi les nouveautés créés alors bien
sûr ça leur dit mais de commencer à
varier encore plus avoir plein de
sous-marion ou de voilà de variétés de
gens qui jouent des trucs réfutés à ça
ça fait plaisir un petit peu aussi
ordinateur pour voir ce que ça fait
tu vois bah c'est typiquement on a on a
Robin ça et d'un Robinson avec son
dinosaure qui a connu
avec son son comment s'appelle son
blackmarder il faisait fureur dans les
tournois qui jouait quand il y avait pas
l'ordinateur quand il y avait pas tous
ces trucs là et maintenant il joue le
Blackmar ici à chaque partie qui joue
quoi parce que les gens ont travaillé
leur avant de Parker donc d'un côté on
progresse si vous voulez et d'un autre
côté
c'est la formation est plus accessible
de partout donc en fait
on peut le voir comme on veut soit c'est
on peut le voir dans le sens de bah oui
on a perdu beaucoup de de ça et ben non
ben voilà soit on peut le voir aussi
dans le sens que
on évolue tu vois et en fait on est tous
plus fort maintenant parce qu'on a accès
à tous à plus d'informations etc
il y a des deux en vrai mais c'est vrai
que moi j'ai commencé à travailler
l'ouverture il y a pas si longtemps que
ça
enfin il y a 10 ans à peu près mais du
coup
je suis passé à 2251 sans travailler
aucune ouverture
donc salut à tous
pour ton compte-rendu des championnat
d'Europe qui se déroule en ce moment et
à Rennes qui fait des coups des fois
bizarres pour déshabiller ses
adversaires
oui bon c'est aussi possible mais après
tu es pas obligé non plus de jouer un
coup qui est mauvais ou quoi juste pour
sortir des fois juste tu vois le fait de
pouvoir connaître plein de choses
différentes ça te permet aussi d'être tu
vois de varier un peu quoi donc là par
contre il s'est passé quoi là car elle
va les prendre c'est 6 sur le terme
prend là j'ai une
découverte comment je finis là
et ben écoute ça va être le point du mal
dire et ouais Fatou toujours pareil
c'est comme quand on fait les
entraînement tactique elle est elle est
là mais toujours un peu plus lente
il faut me laisser le temps
et voilà c'est fini Marwa là c'est même
maths
[Musique]
5 et c'est abondant donc ça va être un
moment je pense de moins elle va jouer
peut-être en vrai je jouerai parce que
tu sais que bon bah c'est perdu donc bah
c'est quelle partie là c'est
après la défaite était comme attendue
mais bon en 15 coups
il a l'air de pas avoir envie
et
ça va être gagné là pour l'équipe du
coup pour l'équipe des Wizard avec le
gain du coup de Costa new qui va arriver
à 8 et demi
ici là c'est une position qui est à
solide quand même pour les noirs
j'aime beaucoup on a pas en début de
stream de ma médoff et je disais que moi
c'est un genre que j'aime beaucoup parce
que à l'époque quand j'aime travailler
le dragon avec les Noirs c'est un genre
que je voyais très souvent dans les
parties tu vois plein plein de référence
de lui il joue beaucoup ça et il joue
très très bien et c'est un des meilleurs
joueurs de
[Musique]
tout ce qui est indienne tout ce qui est
Benko
dragon tout ce qui est fiancetto noir
ici quoi
c'est une grosse référence dans cette
structure là et puis là les belles
positions
peut-être mais c'est un genre qui
vraiment comprend bien les échecs et il
est vraiment bien quoi tout ça
qui jouent des structures en particulier
on peut s'appuyer
c'est un joueur qui est très très bon en
blitz rapide et très dangereux il est
souvent dans les premières tables aussi
dans les tous les championnats
internationaux c'est ce qui est but
c'est rapide il est toujours là toujours
toujours là c'est vraiment un habituel
donc en blé de thérapie je dirais plus
de 2007 ou 2650
c'est mon avis là-dessus vente forest
shimanov ou Laura c'est un gros bordel
qu'est-ce qui se passe dans cette
position
alors je vais remonter rapidement ce qui
s'est passé
je vais vite un ou un pion donné
ses pions
enfin je sais pas c'est normal de donner
des pions pour ouvrir
qui prend il y a du cavalier là le roi
qui est au centre ici c'est chaud
pour H7 donc je pense qu'il veut bouger
le foot tout en défendant je sais pas
trop ce qu'il veut faire d'autres
comme j'ai 4 il veut pas changer
d'avance c'est pour ça qu'il a fait dame
G4 il voulait pas échanger et B5 qui
empêchent du coup le tour B1 tant qu'on
met ça ok parce que la logique tout
racisme
[Musique]
donc là il laisse du coup on prend là tu
aurais pu être possible après ton point
F7 mais bon le roi va partir en B6 c'est
chaud cette histoire quand même qui
avait des G3 on va B7 H5 cavalier bouge
et Carole
alors ça cavalier F5 c'est un coup à la
vente forest très sympa
alors là c'est c'est très très chaud et
s'il prend et dame là quoi
très créatif moi j'avance j'aime
beaucoup vendre forest toujours dans la
créativité
tu as lu c'est un genre en fait
maintenant les ouvertures on en parlait
du fait que
la venue des ordinateurs s'enlève un peu
la créativité dans les ouvertures et ben
lui il profite si tu veux de
l'ordinateur pour être encore plus
créatif il se permet encore plus dingue
mais qu'il va analyser tu vois c'est un
peu de
ce dont parle bleu justement après moi
je suis mal placé parce que j'ai pas
connu les portes
des
possibilités avant mais je ne sais pas
les ordinateurs
toujours dynamique et c'est pas pour
rien aussi que Van forest qui travaille
aussi avec avec Carlsen un morceau de
l'équipe championnat du monde tout ça
c'est pas pour rien
c'est genre ultra créatif comment on
peut vraiment comprendre là-dessus
et qui travaille les échecs tout le
temps et du coup bah ouais c'est cool
d'avoir des gens comme ça dans son
équipe on peut peut-être parler de
l'équilibre par rapport à cette position
aux échecs on essaye toujours de trouver
un décompensation en fait
il y a un certain décompensation un
équilibre quelque part donc entre le
temps entre l'espace et le matériel et
là par exemple on voit qu'il donne du
matériel mais c'est pour c'est pour
autre chose en l'occurrence bah
l'activité des pièces plutôt avec des
pièces noires qui qui jouent pas donc
donc finalement le matériel
d'avance chez les Noirs comme il peut
pas s'exprimer
il compte pas
il sert un petit peu à rien et c'est ça
qui est
c'est ça qui est sympa et c'est là que
quand il y a ce genre de compensation un
peu de
déséquilibre quelque part je suis trop
content parce que je pensais à ça je
suis content ouais moi aussi j'ai pensé
et là je pensais à ça
ou pas on sait pas
les
c'est maintenant
ah non il y a pas mal
OK
de vente forest
la quelle position
je sais pas
tu en es où là
un petit peu
mais bon j'ai aussi celui-là
[Musique]
OK
trois pièces en plus sur l'attaque donc
s'il y a trois attaquants et zéro
défenseur s'il y a quatre attaquants un
défenseur ou voilà ainsi de suite vous
avez compris le principe
forcément un gain
ok voilà vous saurez maintenant donc si
vous avez trois pièces en plus sur
l'attaque dites-vous qu'il y a forcément
quelque chose et gagner
je vais te montrer qu'il y a rien
souvent on a on a souvent plus
attaquants que défenseur donc là
d'ailleurs ça me fait penser à une
partie que j'avais vu de castarov quand
on carpov dans ce fameux match
pas mal à Lyon match Championnat du
monde et il avait sacrifié une partie il
y avait une partie de fou où il avait
servi toutes les pièces et il avait dit
qu'elle va les pompons H6 et chaque
c'est un sacrifice de pièces il avait
dit mais moi je fais un échange c'est
pas un échange c'est un sacrifice tu
vois mais pour lui c'est un échange
parce qu'il disait ben non je change
attaquant quand on est français
et en fait ça paraît ouf quand tu vois
comme ça mais en fait
je vais plus de tu vois j'ai à la fin il
me reste six attaquants contre deux
défenseurs
+ 4
ok donc du coup bon ça c'est ça c'est
chaud là
il y a peu de temps la pendule
je prends la
je retourne
franchement
si je prends là non
et là il va devoir manger peut-être ça
sans et voir s'il arrive à couper
j'ai 5 ton rêve 4
c'est un peu la même là vous avez la
position de lucélant
le petit pont qui va te construire il va
être le pion là voilà je pense qu'il va
abandonner car si vous connaissait
finale et bonsoir et on a vu le score
s'afficher fermez les yeux fermez les
yeux on a rien vu
elle a raison continue
j'ai dû faire un erreur je suis désolé
la caméra elle est pas là
ils sont partis là c'est la fin
ils ont plus le temps
tout seul
avec Jade mais bon du coup vous n'avez
pas la grève vous n'aurez pas la vidéo
c'est la flemme de vouloir régler
je pourrais vous la régler mais après si
vous la règle vous aurez
vous aurez
enfin j'aurai tout un regrets pour la
prochaine on va faire comme ça voilà
on voit que nous
un exemple
je peux vous envoyer la vidéo parce que
je trouve que c'est génial
[Musique]
c'est une vidéo que j'aime énormément
donc elle est en français ou en anglais
au choix
je vais la mettre en anglais pour les
bilingues et la mettre en français pour
les non bilingues
mais c'est mieux en anglais quand même
c'est des vrais voix et tout le VO c'est
mieux et j'adore j'adore de ouf c'est un
documentaire en fait qui a eu pendant le
Championnat du Monde
en 90 ça c'est en anglais
et le suivant ce sera en français au
choix et en fait il y a tous les joueurs
si vous voulez ça dure longtemps ça dure
trois heures un truc comme ça donc c'est
avoir en plusieurs fois mais en gros ce
qui se passe c'est que
tu as les joueurs si tu veux qui qui
font leur partie et à la fin qui débrief
leur partie et chacun leur tour et en
fait ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'on
voit que vraiment
casse pas off et carpov font souvent des
des des comment dire analyses
complètement différentes il pense pas
pareil du tout
pour préparer du tout et
c'est chaud c'est chaud
de de Kasparov où il dit non non mais là
je change donc c'est une partie du
milieu je sais plus quelle c'est mais
c'est une espagnole où il a sacrifié un
cavalier prend
en tout cas je vous envoie le lien enfin
regardez bien c'est c'est génial
peut-être bien
il y a pas de dessin
défendre
et là David qui va gagner la partie du
coup
dame B6
il est pas mal de retournement
ça c'est très bien
les changer ici mettre le four en dessin
on joue solide en plus le pion et là
et la paire de fou voilà
encore une fois
je remets un petit un petit foulard pour
empêcher le roi de venir
qui du coup enterre un petit peu les les
pièces bras donc 2 donc match score
final 9 et demi 6 et demi et en fait il
y a eu deux fois il y a eu trois fois de
deux enfin tout et seulement un set avec
3 et demi 0,5
[Musique]
bras qui auront encore l'occasion de se
refaire lors de la semaine prochaine ils
auront encore un match pour essayer du
coup de
se refaire donc les gars voilà pour les
qualifier il y a encore un match à
gagner pour la calife pour les quarts de
finale donc en tout cas ben demain on
sera de nouveau présent avec du coup
Kevin et donc même heure même heure à
priori donc merci à tous d'avoir suivi
le stream avec nous merci beaucoup Fatou
pour m'avoir accompagné aujourd'hui pour
ce pour ce stream ce fut un plaisir et
du coup moi-même je vais en profiter
pour enchaîner je vais faire un petit
stream sur ma chaîne donc je prends un
petit bref de trois minutes et je vais
me balancer un petit raid
sur ma chaîne voilà donc du coup le
temps que je me connecte sur mon mon Obs
avec mon compte
que je suis une pause 3 minutes en tout
cas j'envoie le Red j'arrive en trois
minutes soyez présent ce qu'ils veulent
voire du Beaujeu en tout cas merci
beaucoup en tout cas Fatou pour pour ta
présence pour tout ça et puis je vous
dis à bientôt à tous à vous abonner
aussi sur YouTube
n'hésitez pas sur Youtube aussi on a vu
que 29% seulement des idées de gens qui
nous regardent sur Youtube sont abonnés
à la chaîne donc abonnez-vous c'est
gratuit et ça nous soutient on va faire
rancœur enfin tout si tu veux
voilà merci à tous j'envoie le raid et
à très bientôt
j'envoie le Red quand même
qui est en train de partir
et tout de suite